[Musique]
vous êtes la yozone roots et squeeze
aujourd'hui on se retrouve de nouveau
sur tir beau tu es d'accord turbine est
bonne parce que là de nouveaux véhicules
et des nouvelles maps propose contests
ça tous ensemble tout de suite et
aujourd'hui tu as dans jours parce que
j'ai enfin réussi à mettre une photo de
moi à la place de la tête de ce pantin
c'est parti on y va c'est moi vous posez
pas de questions ouais c'est ce film là
que je vais bientôt deux mois cette fois
on y va 10 min c'est parti tana et c'est
pas cette pub blizzard ait gare juste
d'accord ok or déjà tu apprends faire un
créneau tout de suite parce que comme ça
qu'on fait aller et conduit bien pu
taper saint-charles volant c'est évident
qu à walbourg il est mort jeune shah joy
qui se cache derrière pour un bon fourbe
au niveau scooter a les moyens en
scooter ok on y va comme ça et c'est
plus d'un se pressent devant ce chat qui
nous regardent comme ça ok on y va oh il
s'enflamme pas une et c'est la chute
d'un arrêt d'accélérer calme toi arrête
d'accélérer mais c'est à prendre au
hockey le chat le plus timide du monde
arrête d'accélérer à leur tour sur la
map il ya looping
alors on va tester avec le scout voici
jim carrey on passe trop de passes
dribbles
vas-y jean auroux garou passe non non
non pas du tout pas du tout
j'avais tous mes espoirs sur toi au lieu
de ne pas décevoir tu préfère dormir ou
de cacher des retours moi oui
ah non pas du tout on aimerait rentrer
oui oui oui c'est comme ça aux reflets
la bronzette au passage il va fausser
autoroute à légumes à l'aide des fonds
ce jim popp n'a pas fait de maître
non mais c'est quoi ce scooter toi
arrête d'accélérer
oh non là je me sens trop mal
l'engagement il a fait hier en l'air ça
va ça va c'est bon tu me regardes jet et
sexy comme ça j'observe les gens qui
passent avec du scotch sur la tête
ah c'est ça qu'on veut aller jim a
étouffé un truc de fou allez passer tout
mon gars hopley aller oui oui allez au
revoir jean rejetée mais au revoir corps
jetés mais finalement au revoir qui
n'est pas sous mon corps je sui team et
je me cache derrière mon tort c'est même
plus est fait ce qui bouge qui sont
basses un pont d'arc stade au dessus là
ça s'est fini à base de ja je dérange et
bonjour je suis le plus
bonjour je te deuxième bus s'écraser
contre le mur et pour finir bonjour ça
se passe en plus mais je m'incruste t'en
fais pas c'est une partie du programme
sont bronzés ya pas de problème c'est
parfait james et sa convenance 18 ans
puis par honda au petit on a dit que tu
t'en fais pas au revoir qu'à 10 ce qui
passe le gars dit ah il m'a déçu aussi
je suis double déçu il reste dans ce
[ __ ] de cannes est le premier pas ce
nom oui c'est bien tu restes tu restes
c'est pas mal tu as le droit faire et
willy ça t'apprendra à bollaert en
filaire
je m'en bats les states est étroite ok
allez allez allez jim jim descente cette
photo des sortes cette photo est pas au
courant dit non tu as de la caresser
c'est bien aussi c'est bien voilà les
joueurs ont pu s'écarter en l'air non
manon les re savent pas j'aime il est
content il peut encore faire sacrer bas
c'est votre problème
allez tu me déçois pas tomber les
quilles sont déjà tombées non non non
oui c'est nouveau ça mine fils ou alors
j'ai jamais vu petit oiseau je t avais
tellement baissé au revoir il a l'air
tellement content sur son nouveau vélo
c'est vraiment un bon papa allait jim
pas au nom les mines
le backflip non c'est un nuc le nuc le
nuc grande journée sur le post obtient
ce méga fourbe
oui oui hayden pièce à denver où es-tu
il a bien hâte et les bornes pour pas
que je puisse se poursuivre il est où là
bas au bout j'aime bien faire du p'tit
vélo mais j'ai aussi du grand véhicule
en stock
oui à huit ans et demi n'était pas un
problème vas-y et camions je compte sur
toi je peux plus être parmi ce bond
camion camions les banques qui font
qu'on allait remettre dont j'allais
faire du style le style est en fait on
est on en est là c'est l'heure de tuer
la pirater les faux
le nouvel airbag comment on peut
contourner ces bornes la pucelle sont
fous quand je démarre
l faut qu'on s'en va t inquiète pas
d'accord alors là jim espion jen 007 yes
boga ou qu'est ce que ça fait un petit
temps plein à merci hayden soit padeg
non non ils remonteront monte à rabat
sous le sable j allais dire mon niveau
au liban serait pas on se prépare [ __ ]
mais en fait c'est un simulateur de
salto arrière quoi watts mais non je me
fais trop dépendants propres camions
kouao oui mon cas oui rien ne peut
l'arrêter
rien du tout pas même ce bus à moins que
c'est ça qu'on veut
oui disent non non non où est mon
scooter ils l'ont kidnappé déjà ce bus
les deux virages trop parfait pour être
vrai la peinture sur les vidz interdire
et aux charges publiques ou pas avoir un
appartement alors là c'est la mode c'est
la contravention maximus
il s'appelait maximus c'était le plus
gros véhicule conçu par l'être humain
il arrivait à prendre les virages et à
faire l'amour infini en même temps
qu'ils ont remis retomber sur votre
camion bac c'est lui c'est dans la
phrase choc femelle qu est-ce qui a
c'est ça un étalon c'est ça qu'on veut
un high non non non tu t'es trompé c'est
le camion qui voulait te laisse pas moi
non arrête arrête de me toucher
hop je n'ai plus de jambes je n'ai plus
de bras mais par contre j'ai un gros pif
à l'espoir fait vivre
c'est moi sur mon foot je déchirerai
cela fait du poing sur les fesses à
l'aller oui non mais en fait y'a un
petit rebord qui nous piège l'a1 et qui
lâche des boulons noir et qui disparaît
ensuite onieva au aviv alors ils tuent
les cacher la tête dans le cabinet et
oui massive ussel gagné ont réussi sa
coupe non c'est une voiture les cadeaux
vous pas que les voitures ça suffit
direct je suis le chat pétales croisons
les doigts et croyons en la chance au
nom âge y croyez ah c'est bon c'est bon
cette fois c'est au lab une tête de chat
sortir de l'écran comme il y avait de la
dynamite dans ce train comme un espace
jeunes chats où es-tu jeune chaton a ou
le voilà bah oui alors le vois plus mon
gars oui non au revoir à scooter chacun
son frein en overnight ça vous est c'est
parti
c'est quoi ça déjà donc à juste vingt
véhicules sur quatre mètres carrés quoi
bon au revoir jeune chat lan orange
devrait passer au dessus avec la force
centrifugeuses de la nation ça devrait
voilà ah non il aller plus haut que moi
et il a gagné intervilles on applaudit
bien fort
on l'appelait tonique at il sauté
d'étoilés plus dangereux du monde pour
intérêts air de manière parfaitement
brutale comme ça où un skate avec une
jambe salaires pas très stable d'accord
ok je joue même pas que ça tombe c'est
parti ok ok attend l'humanité ricoché
sur le trottoir le vélo hockey a fait à
manses vélo me fait tomber puis qu'à sa
structure histoire je me fasse bien
voyez comme une merde [ __ ] de traître
puisque c'est comme ça je prends à mon
scooter mais pas mal on est pas mal on
est pas mal tu t'en puis oui mon gars
c'est fini c'est fini à être malade et
trop chaud à red bull j'ai fait 63 et la
jouer en position foetale sur ma moto
puisque j'ai peur qu'on la grèce
normalement un oiseau symbole à partir
de là il devrait faire à peu près 200
points attendons mais là il ya un
problème quoi qu'en d'oiseaux c'est un
imposteur ces appels
lattes avec 450 mètres pour apprendre à
voler on y voit la poule à il se
redresse il vole un peu annoncé le mur
invisible
ben oui mais pas attention mais
invisible c'est la base qui ont un noyau
et la perfection désintégration succès
déverrouiller seller de toudic à te dis
ok j'en ai marre de jouer quatre donc
jamais une photo de moi ça va c'est beau
à les pythies aller pitié on y va petit
oui c'est bien pitt il ya du progrès ou
pas trop à m c'est une voiture qui
revient le chercher
bon qu elle est bien réglé il finit bien
il finit pas bien mal
k o non ça fait passer nulle cette
partie pythie voilà comme ça voilà comme
ça et le panier voilà car a demandé qui
s'est pris un bus nommé m c'est pas bien
la curiosité
tu devrais pas te fait comme ça t'as pas
voulu m'écouter c'est ton problème un
piti voilà un million deux cent mille
personnes qui sont décédées par ta faute
betty est ce que ça passe et déjà déjà
le départ est un peu brouillée bowe et
au toit bonheur tout de suite là bouby
gbagbo accepte tab estimé hôpital à tous
les fons et il est vivant
royal effet la danse des bras a plus
trop la ferme jaffa sa place et voilà
les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette
troisième vidéo sur turbo 10 tirs beau
tu es c'est ta faute ça voilà tu tu
rajoutes moi ça me perturbe sur turbo 10
- j'espère si vous aura plu si c'est le
cas elle ne s'était pas lavé la vidéo ça
fera vraiment plaisir
et puis on se retrouve très bientôt dans
une nouvelle vidéo tout le monde y
envoie rapiti thébaux la tête à l'envers
tu sais
[Musique]